it's great to welcome to the program
today Eitan Hirsch who is an associate
professor of political science at Tufts
University and also author of the book
politics is for power it's so great to
have you on eight on thank you for
having me so one of the things you you
talk about and write about in the book
which I find super interesting is that
often times those who are what we might
call political hobbyists where they
follow politics almost the way you might
follow a sports team where there seems
to be a significant kind of
entertainment component they're often
not actually activists in their
community necessarily around issues or
candidates and that this can cause well
it can cause a lot of different things I
guess I'll leave it to you to tell me
what what the repercussions are but how
did you first start sort of
investigating this and what are the
repercussions of that that phenomenon
yes I was looking at a bunch of
political science data you know what do
surveys behavioral data tell us about
how people are following the news
engaging in activism partisan
cheerleading and yeah I had this
realization that was a little bit
uncomfortable which is that most of the
ways that people are engaging in
politics is fuels it feels more like a
hobby than actual power seeking like
trying to move politics or move
government and direction that they want
and so it's true that like if you're a
real political activist you probably are
consuming a lot of news but like 90% of
people who are consuming a lot of news
are not doing any real politics so it's
mostly just you know news consumption
arguing online debating at the kitchen
table and being anxious by yourself and
so what effect does that have in terms
of who the actual activists are and does
that skew the priorities of the actual
activists because there are so many
hobbyists that aren't really
participating yeah so right there's a
lot of stuff for one thing the people
who are most engaged first of all have
generally stronger ideological views and
the people who are the hobbyist right in
order to get off your couch and do
something you have to really care and
right now it looks like the people who
most care are people who are really
ideologically motivated or people who
have
real strong local networks like they are
part of a church that meets regularly
and so they're kind of brought into a
coalition of activism through that so a
lot of the people who you know they say
they care they're worried about the
country most of them if unless there's
something I you know there's something
in them that push them to do something
they're not doing anything the other
thing is that hobby ISM is itself
creating some problems so if we're on
the couch responding to certain kinds of
politics with our attention or with like
maybe throw in a $5 donation we might be
making politics worse if the kinds of
politics were incentivizing is kind of
people who play politics like a game so
you know I give the example a lot of
congressional hearings or primary
debates where politicians are looking to
make a viral video of himself so that
they can get dollars in their campaign
coffers and if we sitting at home like
are waiting for them to fight or be
provocative or say something extreme
we're actually the ones incentivizing
them to act like that
so we at home it's not just that we're
not doing anything or wasting our time
although I think we are doing that we're
also in some ways making politics worse
I feel like we sort of saw this in the
first Democratic primary debate where
Michael Bloomberg participated where
there was a lot of lead up to what's it
going to be like with Bloomberg there
within the first 30 seconds Elizabeth
Warren used the phrase horseface lesbian
and fat broads and in quoting things
that Michael Bloomberg was accused of
saying the ratings were crazy I had a
bunch of people tell me this was like
the best debate and then I said well
what was it because there was the least
policy discussion of any debate that I
can remember it was cartoonish from an
entertainment perspective I could see
why somebody who's looking for fireworks
enjoyed it but we probably learned the
least about what it is that these
individuals would do if they were the
Democratic vote the elected president
hypothetically yeah and I think it's
easier for people to take this point if
they look at the other side so if you're
a Democrat you should take some lesson
from the fact that by far the biggest
rating of any primary debate or any
general election debate or debates where
Donald Trump is on the stage that that
vacation that kind of outrage that's
what gets attention and it's true
whether it's on the left or on the right
meanwhile there are really important
debates happening all over the country
you know for like governor where no
one's paying attention because it is a
actual policy debate on real concrete
issues but without that antagonism it's
no fun for people to watch and the only
reason you're engaging in politics is
for fun then you know you're not gonna
watch one of the things that I wanted to
ask you about which I don't know if has
come up recently in the interviews
you've done is there are probably some
hobbyists that we would be better served
by them not actually getting involved so
for example white nationalists on
Twitter I would prefer they only be
tweeting and not actually be doing white
nationalist stuff in their communities
is there always some other side to these
analyses that has to be considered where
there are coalition's for example like
under Donald Trump that are more
activated than they've been in a while
where we want to relegate them to the
least visibility possible so I think on
average people whose preferences are
more moderate and actually more left are
the ones who are really succumbing to
hobby ISM the most it's absolutely true
and I say this quite clearly in the book
that there's a you know a lot of people
who could take lessons from the book
from all sides the political spectrum
and it's just a matter of whether the
people that I like or you like or anyone
likes wins on that front and right now I
think there's a mistake that a lot of
liberals are making in particular which
is that they think that you know Donald
Trump is doing really well among these
like online white nationalists or
something like that and they're
mistaking that like no actually most of
his coalition are not people with
extreme views there are people who might
not even like Donald Trump they might be
embarrassed by Donald Trump but because
they're connected to a community of
people and because they have actual you
know preferences on issues like you know
reproductive rights or whatever they're
going to get out to vote even when the
candidate is not exciting and I think
that the Hobby is that you know if every
was to be more participatory I think
you've probably move in a moderate
direction or a probably left direction -
but it's true anyone can take the lesson
of being an activist no matter who there
is there some degree to which the notion
that doing some paying attention is
always better than newt doing none maybe
is questioned by some of what you write
in the sense that paying attention for
example if there was a study from P IPA
years ago kind of a famous study that
found that if you exclusively or
primarily get your news from Fox News
you actually are likely to know less on
a factual basis about what's going on in
the world then if you don't watch any of
this stuff and presumably just talk to
people and read books and and so on and
so forth
where does that fit in to your analysis
in terms of the sort of degrees of
involvement that people have with what's
going on in political news the political
systems elections etc so yeah I mean
look I don't want to judge anyone for
how they want to spend their leisure
time right yes but but if you are like
obsessively spending your hours like
watching congressional hearings and
impeachment trial and presidential
primaries and following the horse race
of the primary you're not learning stuff
that's useful for you to be a citizen
and so I think people mistake
following that stuff for being
politically engaged involved you know
there are people out there right now
because they follow the primaries the
Democratic primaries so intently they
know more about the rules of the Iowa
caucuses and they know about how power
flows through their own state or local
political party you know I read the
newspaper every morning and like for the
people who the day before spent four
hours watching an aggression of hearing
it takes me three minutes to get what I
needed to get out of that in the morning
paper and so I would say look leisure
time is pretty zero-sum you can't just
spend your time on everything and if
you're only prioritizing national drama
and horse race stuff you probably don't
have time to also pay attention to the
really important stuff going on where
you can have an impact but you're also
just like learning about politics in
this in this way that's really yes it's
just not going to tell you what you need
to do to be involved so I look at this
make you worse person I just don't think
particularly good citizen I think that
folks should recognize that if they're
following that stuff it's more for their
own entertainment than for anything else
can you talk a little bit about why that
type of more direct community engagement
is down among those who have college
degrees that's super interesting yeah
there's a lot of reasons for this but
that's right so the most the hobby ISM
behavior like people spending most
amount of time in non engaged ways is
among this college-educated class
particularly college-educated white
citizens who follow a lot of news they
know a lot of facts but they're not
engaged in their communities and you
know one question is I go so why is that
why is that true and party answer is
that for people like this you know
they're pretty comfortable and they have
comfortable lives and so they're not
particularly eager to get off their
couch but on the Left I think you have a
special problem which is that suppose
you're on the Left if you say even if
people ask you what issues do you care
most about you might say like the
environment or racial equality or
something like that and then there
really are plenty of state and local
versions of those policy fights about
say the environment of racial equality
the problem is you're going to have a
lot of disagreement with your neighbors
and your people in your town and your
state about about those issues like you
might if it costs you nothing to say I
want a green new deal or I want an
international climate change it costs
you a lot to say
I want our gas taxes to go up in our
state I want to pay all sorts of costs
and not just me I want my neighbors to
pay those costs to pay for those bills
now now all of a sudden like for one
thing you might not be so liberal if
that's what you were before and you
actually don't want to fight with your
neighbors about it and so where your
reaction is to say oh only the important
stuff is happening at the national level
I can't pay attention to that I'll just
I mean I can only pay attention the
national stuff I won't deal with the
political stuff because it's too hard
and my neighbors disagree with me and
you know maybe I don't care as much as I
say I care that seems to be much easier
with the sort of modern social media
status quo that we have right in the
sense that in terms of what you're
posting on social media it's much easier
to have
broader appeal and more responses likes
whatever if you're posting about
something nationally that the United
States might do then if you're posting
about what your town should do in terms
of frequency of recycling pickup or
whatever the case may be
is this significantly exacerbated by
social media yeah I think it's
exacerbated by social media because the
the relationships are shallower so you
know what I often say about this is like
if you can tell if you're engaging in
politics as a hobby if no one is
depending on you like if you could just
stop giving your hot takes online for a
week or two and no one's gonna call you
and be like oh we really missed your
hotcakes like with you know where were
you this whole time like no one's gonna
do that because those relationships
aren't really serious because you're not
actually asking anyone no one's
depending on you if you're engaged in
politics in the real way what you're
trying to move people you're part of an
organization with goals and strategies
if you take a step back people are gonna
be like hey we need you here and so I
think that it's because those
relationships are so shallow online
because we can get that emotional
catharsis so easily that we've
transformed politics even more into a
hobby as opposed to a power seeking
behavior when it comes to what people
can actually do there's a whole bunch of
you know range of things that people
talk about we have sort of at one end
you sign an online petition maybe you
you send a fax to you know your member
of Congress or you call or email or
something like that on the other end we
have these ideas of if you really want
to make change you have to coordinate
general strikes all the way up to
strategic you know loan defaults to
[ __ ] an economy you know there's like
very very very broad range can you talk
a little bit about what you see in terms
of risk reward or work rewards so to
speak as the areas of real involvement
that are most effective sure we can talk
for a long time about this but the short
thing I would say is that think about
how to convert your own vote as I said
is it into more votes like do you have
it in you based on your time that you
can put into politics to get a hundred
other people to take some action they
want otherwise to you know there's going
to be some local fight or a state fight
in your area
wherever you live that's about some
issue that you care about right if
you're on the right maybe it's about
religious liberty or economic
development if you're on the Left it's
probably about the environment or
schools or health care and you know like
can you get a bunch of people who are
not engaged in local and state issues to
vote how you want them to vote and how
would you go about doing that you'd have
to like build some trust with them make
sure that they think that you have the
same values as them be empathetic to
what they're saying and you know I think
one of the things that the organizers I
study in this book are doing really well
is they're really counting votes they're
saying like you know there's one guy is
98 years old of the book people call me
Ukrainian boss controls a thousand votes
his precinct has three times the turnout
rate of all the precincts around it and
everyone a tribute to this one person
who's like built a lot of respect for
his neighbors and they all vote how he
thinks they could vote I think that's
very tangible for anyone if they start
thinking about okay if I can convince
one other person I've doubled the power
of my vote if I can convince a hundred
people and so people will have different
levels of their willingness to
participate in this kind of politics but
if you were engaged in politics the real
way which is again with a strategy with
a goal trying to move the garment
forward you got to think about in terms
of counting votes counting voices
instead of paying attention to
interesting stuff along those lines for
at the national level Senate races
governor etc I've long suspected that if
you consider the sort of time and energy
required to get someone to to flip their
votes versus simply because we don't
have mandatory voting finding people who
are unlikely to vote but already agree
with you my instinct is the time and
energy is way better spent just getting
the vote out with people you don't have
to convince rather than arguing with
people and I think you know imagining me
arguing with a trumpet in in North
Dakota trying to get them to change the
rope versus just finding 10 Democratic
votes it seems instinctually accurate
but but is it do you have a feeling
about that yeah we for sure no that's
true like if you are if you're in a
situation where it's a Democratic versus
Republican election and you have the
choice of like trying to persuade a
bunch of people on the other side or
turnout the people you
we actually know a lot more from great
experiments about how to increase
turnout without trying to persuade
anyone by giving people reminders by
taking people to the polls by like
making voting easier for them what I
would say is though on a lot of the
issues that people care about there's
much more persuasion to be done than we
might think and that's because you know
some people say like they live in a
bubble a lot of people say like oh I
live in a liberal bubble or a
conservative bubble there's no one I
need to convince and what they mean by
that is like everyone on the
presidential election around them is
basically going to vote the same way but
when it comes to actual issues and those
issues are more manifest in local and
state elections people are not such an
above all people have really different
perspectives on this you know some
people don't want to have a 5 cent
increase in the gas tax some people
don't really want to solve a massive
transportation problem in a region and
so there actually is a lot more
persuasion to be done than you might
think it's just not going to be in the
terms of like you know a Fox News and
MSNBC viewer fighting with each other
that's not going to be ever very
productive absolutely absolutely agree
with you there we've been speaking with
Eitan Hirsch who teaches a political
science at Tufts University is also
author of the book politics is for power
which we are linking to 8 on so great
having you on and I really appreciate
your time
thanks for having me